hi there hi christina how's it going it
is going well how about you wonderful
i
think this character seems like she
would just be an absolute blast to play
so what was it about her that intrigued
you that made you want to play her she
just seems ridiculously awesome
you're you're so on the money um
um i wanted to play her because it is
just too much fun i love anytime a
character is unpredictable and has a lot
of colors and a rich backstory which
this has in spades um
i love that she is funny and fabulous
and over the top and evil and villainous
and then sometimes child like in her own
way um and then the next minute like
truly terrifying so this was an
opportunity for me to just like
have fun and
and ham it up and and you know go for it
i also love to change it up and i have
never played a witch before and i was
like all right this is very different
from how people have been seeing me for
the past couple years on jessica jones
so
uh let's let's be the big bad um
so yeah this was a
dream role and
something that i have too much fun doing
did you have a real sense of her right
away i mean did you
know how kind of crazy and wild she
could get did you have a full sense of
that or was that something that
developed through conversations yeah
that's something that develops and you
know you find the character more and
more by sitting with it um
i sort of always approach my characters
like okay what's the first thing i
notice and then start digging digging
digging and you want to always be
informed by her backstory you know i
don't want to give it away for people to
see the movie but her backstory like
informs why she is the way she is why
she dresses the way she does
and why she's there so um starting from
that place and then just
the more comfortable like you get with
something the more fun and more free
you're able to be i also um always work
with my long time acting teacher
marjorie valentine and we would just
like
push and push and push and find more
colors um
yeah so this was this was definitely
like a roll of a lifetime
do you see her as terrifying do you see
her as misunderstood do you see her as a
victim of her circumstances how do you
view her see that that's what's so great
about this character is she's all of
those things um
you know she's somebody who
found herself in really horrible
circumstances
um and then arguably even worse
circumstances
and decided to you know what i'm just
gonna like
take this magic and have fun because
why not um so
i think she's a little bit of everything
and that's what's so great and that's
what i look for as an actress like
somebody you kind of can't put in a box
this is also something of a fashionista
witch
what was it like to see her wardrobe
come together how would you describe her
fashion sense yeah so her fashion sense
is inspired by her tastes that she had
as a child um
and now that she has magic and is
emotionally kind of stuck and stunted as
you know a child um it's
like how can she have the most fun with
it collaborating with our amazing
costume designer um autumn she basically
had a look book and an idea before i
came on board that i
was super into and we just kept
collaborating back and forth on like the
direction to take her the idea was to do
something we have not seen before um pay
homage to like the great witches and
stay in the world but
but really do something fresh and
original and unique and i think um
she really hit it out of the park with
these costumes and her brain her
imagination for for these looks
was just so much fun for me
yeah i mean there's the fashion there's
the blue hair but can we also talk about
the leather gloves with the fingernails
what were those like to wear can you
actually do anything
um they were we had some tricks
you know on getting them off kind of
quickly and easily so i could go be with
my baby and not be dangerous
um but it was like you know a way for
her to be like fabulous and because the
magic comes from her hands you want it
to be
something like you know that your eye
catches and something that elevates the
magic also there's like you know
freddy krueger kind of vibes with those
like blades on her fingers
um yeah so it's just like
really fresh
like fun thing to do that is also like
fabulous and practical
yeah i mean how did your
child feel about the look was he ever
freaked out by the hair or the clothing
or was he very approving of the whole
ensemble so i would practice my lines on
on him and
he thought it was the funniest thing
ever he would just laugh and laugh and
laugh at me i still will sometimes
practice the lines and he will even
himself go like
ah
fun language because of this character
um he was down with the blue hair and he
sat with me in here and makeup a lot i
actually put my costumes on
on set normally like your actors have a
trailer with all your costumes and
people come help you get ready in your
room but because i had my baby in there
i didn't want him to be too freaked out
by it so i would kind of just like get
to set and like throw everything on
there which is like
not glitterous
which is like you know it's dirty and
we're figuring it out but i i didn't
want him to be
too thrown or confused so
um
yeah i had to like
change the change the the way we do
things a little bit to um accommodate
the working mom life
you directed an episode of jessica jones
and you're directing again with girl in
the woods
what was it that interested you and that
and made you want to get so heavily
involved with that project
yeah so direct theme is like
sort of an extension on
on
what i
already
like love and about the industry and
love about storytelling um i was so
fortunate to
have um an amazing career that i got to
um
you know observe and and
and take in all of these amazing
directors around me um on jessica jones
knowing that character through and
through and understanding that story and
understanding melissa rosenberg and what
she was going for
um she you know supported me to take the
step and and sit in that chair um it's
something i absolutely love and
it's a lot of work but it's one of the
most like rewarding creative
jobs there is um
so yes i just finished directing uh the
pilot and first four episodes of girl in
the woods which is gonna come out
peacock also for halloween and
and that is a is a story about
another like young female badass monster
hunter um which i'm just thrilled for
everyone to see
i'm sensing a theme with the badassness
yeah why not we need there's never too
many badass women
did it feel very different to direct
something that you weren't also acting
in
yeah it's it's actually i find it kind
of hard to um direct and act um
so it was nice to be able to
just direct
just directing so much work
uh and not have to like be in here and
make up but they were definitely like
the actors on that show were so
fantastic that i definitely had a few
moments where i was like oh i wish i
could do a scene with them i wish i
could like
can i get in the movie somehow um
yeah so it just depends on what the what
the material is um yeah
well thank you for talking about all of
it you seem like you're having the most
fun so thank you
christina so great to meet you thanks a
lot